all right
rose rose where'd you grow up where are
you from
originally um richmond california and
you grew up with both your parents
kind of sort of not really tell me about
your childhood both parents
um no just my father it's just dad
what happened to mom uh it doesn't
matter
how was how was your childhood i was
rough
confusing tiresome
like anybody else's no abuse nothing
traumatic um
nothing too traumatic no nothing that
the regular child doesn't go through
so so at what point did you kind of your
sexuality become aware of you
um it's not my sexuality it's more like
um i don't think of it as my sexual
orientation it's my gender
and who i am as a person i what i'm
doing right now
when you're transitioning you're
basically trying to mirror the person
that you are in the inside
on the outside because i definitely
don't match the outside of my exterior
um inside feels i feel different i feel
like
i don't know i just can't explain it
it's something i mean i would love to
explain it to the world but
it's just something i'm not ready for
yet
yeah and how long how long have you been
transitioning yes i've been transgender
my whole life
i've been transitioning for about
10 years close to it and when you made
that transition as you're making this
transition do you lose
friends or do you find um i lost a lot
of friends i lost a lot of family
i lost a lot of fake friends um i lost
i didn't really lose anything if you
really think about it that's what i was
gonna say
i didn't lose them i just so the friends
that you hold on to
oh the friends that i yeah i've had some
really good support systems that's great
really good support system it's nice to
hear
so you're here in the tenderloin san
francisco what are you
uh doing for money now um well i
dress like that well just like this you
know this is
don't categorize me but you know i'm
just free
i'm i'm a free spirit like i don't care
what people think
um they can look at me they can stare at
me they can take pictures all they want
um i just feel like i'm a human being
that deserves to
live and deserves to be treated with
respect and equality just as well as
everyone else
do you get a hard time sometimes i do
very much what kind of stuff have you
um i'll be walking down the street and
somebody would be like that's a boy
or um that's a man and i'm glad that
they can understand that i'm glad that
they could see that
um but a regular man um usually doesn't
pay attention to us
unless that's what he's attracted to so
a grown man usually keeps his mouth
stuck
shut and minds his own business worried
about him and his wife and his kids
instead of worrying about another man or
another transgender the ones who get
upset by it are the ones
yeah who really want it and who secretly
want to take me around the corner who do
you sh it's amazing i'll be walking down
the street and out of a whole group of
five guys
there'd be two guys to sit there and be
talking [ __ ] about me and really really
other guys aren't saying that
they're just looking because they're
noticing what he's saying you're fun to
look at right or whatever the case may
be
and i mean i've been in a situation
where there was a transgender woman who
was i don't want to use the word clocky
but she
was very hard and um beginning of her
trans
transition and they were making fun of
her and the guy said can you believe
that's a [ __ ] voter
and i said you might want to be careful
who you're talking to because you never
know what you're running into
in the city you know you never know what
kind of person you're going to meet and
he clearly just disrespected me because
i'm transgender too and i stand with her
yeah yeah it's an interesting reaction
that people have
isn't it so are drugs are part of the
picture for you um they were
there's a lot of drugs in this
neighborhood there's a lot of drugs in
this neighborhood
they you have to be very careful what
you do you have to be very
careful who you do it with um all kinds
of stuff you just got to be careful
what have you played around with um only
like ecstasy
meth um
that's about it marijuana is not a drug
okay i smoke it every day because it
calms me down
um it helps with my anxiety
i haven't really tried too many drugs
you haven't
i have it is there something about this
lifestyle that
kind of you find yourself drawn to
yeah you're basically living where do
you live are you on the street
no i live on hyde street so you have an
apartment or um i have
yeah something like that yeah a hotel
it's a hotel that's turned into
apartments right
but but being in this neighborhood and
it's um
i struggle it's a struggle it's a big
struggle
i walk out my house every day to being
threatened
laugh that humiliated and after a while
your skin gets so thick that you just
forget about it you stop hearing people
you stop giving a [ __ ] excuse my
language yeah no but i think
you become like a stronger i'm
unapologetically
trans does that make sense i'm not going
to apologize for anything
i'm not going to stop being me for
nothing in the world
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life mind your business
for me my my business
and this was something you were born
with right what being trans
yes my parents knew as a young age and
your parents were cool with it
not every parent wants their child to go
through that it's really because
it's not because of who you're gonna be
it's because of what you're gonna go
through
and i didn't understand that at a young
age and they were trying to force me to
be someone i wasn't and look what
happened
because they didn't fully accept me and
because they couldn't accept me
and support me i just didn't give a [ __ ]
what they said
what kind of crazy i mean what what's
the most extreme thing you've seen here
in the tenderloin lots of violence lots
of
um i've seen the craziest thing was
someone dying
that i think was and bringing him back
to life me and my friend was
very extreme i was walking down the
street one day and some lady just gave
me a narcan
and i didn't really know what it was but
since at the time i was doing meth i was
like okay well maybe i should keep it
because there's fentanyl going around
and um one of my friends i'm not gonna
use any names
but one of my friend's husband
had overdosed in an alley and my hotel
room was right there
above this alley so like i heard the
screaming and then yelling and my friend
was running down the hall
i mean running down the street screaming
like someone called the cops somebody
called 9-1-1 and like all i can remember
was that that lady gave me
a narcan so i grabbed the narcan and
went downstairs and put it in his nose
and he went from purple to like pale
color so he was breathing
um it was pretty crazy but if it was if
i didn't do that he would be dead right
now
do you find getting a straight job
difficult with with your
identity a straight job yeah working at
a
department store or working in an office
something like that there's the double
sword
to that i'm gonna have to say that yes
society makes it very hard for us to get
jobs due to the fact that we're trans
and everybody wants to come com comment
on our lifestyle everybody wants to say
something and
me personally i'm i don't give a [ __ ]
type person so if i hear you say
something about me nine times out of ten
i'm going to ask you if you want to
fight
or if what is that any of your business
you know what i mean like what is it in
your business what i am and what i'm
doing with my life it doesn't have an
effect on your life because if it does
you're focused too hard on me do you
know what i mean
but um they make it very hard um i've i
had a job i have multiple i had multiple
jobs i worked for denny's i worked for
metro i worked for um the sopapilla
factory in new mexico
i worked for tgijp out here in san
francisco
um that was the best job i've ever had
that was the last job i had
he's raised a woman
i mean i think i think you're convincing
enough that you probably fool a lot of
people
i don't want to fool anybody i just want
to live my life and have people accept
me for who i am oh that's great
it's very healthy and where do you see
your life going from here
um i don't know how old are you i'm 25.
you're a kid i'm a baby i'm younger than
half these people
did you go to high school i did
and what kind of kid were you in high
school i was like okay kid you're
not yet rebellious yeah i was trans you
were in high school yes i was
and how was that how was that that must
have been tough right mm-hmm
teenagers can be cruel
i guess you could say i could be crow
too
you can be you're tough i can hook my
own
all right rose thank you so much for
talking with me you're welcome and good
luck out there thank you all right
you